j'ai approché monsieur chirac si jamais
ce sera au salon d'hercule à pourquoi ça
serait faire ce que j'avais vu tout le
protocole je me souviens que moi j'ai
voulu prendre une photo avec lui ne
serait-ce que passer le bras autour du
du président pour préparer tout y est
comme on a tous envie de faire je me
suis pris une mandale pour le bras de
l'art et de la sécurité quelque chose de
mémorable
j'en viens justement las à la question
de point de vue sécurisé à l'élément
macao
moi j'apprends que quelques minutes
avant cet individu est vu sur un
rassemblement anti macron avec des
agriculteurs des gens colère des gilets
jaunes et autres citoyens c'est vrai
c'est vraiment d'être un type fait pour
passer le barrage c'est peut-être une
question que je poserai à monsieur quand
moi je vois que sur paris et le samedi
qui peut pas faire cinq mètres sont
finis au gnouf ou avec les amandes
insinué giroud ou est-ce que ça a péché
comment ça se fait quand je pose la
question comment ce mec a pu passer est
d'autant plus que la preuve en est c'est
que une fois de plus les équipes de
quotidiens interview c'est la classe en
dix ans une heure avant on attend macron
quels sont les rg à ce moment là parce
que c'est rien c'est du par année alors
macao au niveau de la sécurité là est ce
qu'il ya eu il ya eu des failles ou pas
du tout c'est vrai c'est etc voilà
s'était ému abl ça c'est arrivé avec la
porte et il ya je suis un petit souci
passé je suis pas contre tous mes
anciens collègues pas celle là vous
voyez à l'épaule droite du chef tu vois
quand il voit attaquer là que jarvis qui
touche le pays
tu vois il touche s'il avait un couteau
paillasse et entaillé le chef est le
seul souci c'est pas qu'on travaille
dans la fosse normalement dans la fosse
il doit avoir à mettre la sécu qui a oui
c'est ça au kazoo parce que tu as
système une fois au salon de
l'agriculture en quoi que ce soit et il
ya quelqu'un qui a pris les chefs il
atteignit non à huy a maintenu qu'il a
tenue qui atténue le chef man tu avais
fait appel ici bien sûr et certain la
barrière la pub tout ça là où il avait
été mis plusieurs temps tout ça
donc c'était juste question dans la
fosse il devait y avoir quelqu'un pour
d'accord ça ça n'a pas été fait c'est
vrai que là là là aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron tu penses qui va aller
encore au contact comme ça qui va
demander à sa sécurité qu'est ce qui se
passe là sur un coup comme ça tu penses
qu emmanuel macron il a gueulé après il
a dit lévesque s'est passé
adaptant les chefs il a toujours
l'adrénaline du public
c'est pas la première fois à amiens
pendant les élections tous allons
devenir en était là les ouvriers au quoi
il voulait nous mettre aux savons tous à
la méla pas eu peur d'une des parties
qu'il a toujours été meilleur à nos
contacts mais ce que tu penses que la
sécurité s'est pris un savon
non qu'on y retourne deuxième fois la
sécurité tu vois il n'empêche pas il est
encore devant les mercis ans est inscrit
douze jeux juste une question à poser à
bernard montiel on dit tous il ya une
légende qui dit que je lis thyssenkrupp
a savez peut-être mais quoique brigitte
macron à extrêmement peur pour emmanuel
macron mais physiquement elle a peur qui
lui arrive un accident ça cet incident
là ce soir elle salue en parler
forcément
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle peut lui
dire vraiment essaye d'éviter maintenant
d'aller trop contact parce qu'on est sûr
c'est qu'elle a très peur pour elle et
pour les intérêts je crois que c'est
soit qu'elle lui dit depuis le début ça
mais lui il est très tactile en plus ils
adorent ça et voyait mal malgré cet
incident alors en fait il faut rappeler
quand même qu'il n'était pas prévu qu'il
s'arrête à cette place là c'est ça il
est descendu de lui-même parce que les
gens basculé à la personne qu'on avait
personne derrière s'est de lui-même
qu'il est descendu de la voiture et qui
a étalé face aux gens parce qu'il aime
le contact et qu'il a besoin
on lui reproche seulement à ces cas
l'elysée justement il est bloqué de tous
qu'il entend rien là il est allé et
d'ailleurs tout de suite après il a
continué à saluer des gens